the fbi is insidiously powerful
i don't care if it means i die what's
going on in the fbi lab has got to be
stopped is it intentional that you don't
want to have a lot of limelight and you
don't want people to see your story is
that a kind of a
intentional thing on your end patrick
the issue is not me the issue is
human rights violations the issue is
civil rights violations the issue is
truth
in our justice system what involvement
did you have in the world trade center
bombing case
that was a big bomb the pan am 103 i was
in the o.j simpson trial
i saw a lot of things that were
happening that were bad
wait let me let me get the straights has
it always been where fbi has been more
powerful than the president
until they met mr trump then they met
themselves
joe biden did not want to get mixed up
with upsetting the fbi
why do you think that is j edgar hoover
was a very powerful man
and his legacy is one of blackmail they
are absolutely
terrified of the boogeyman and the
boogeyman is you it's the
medium is there still a inspiration is
there still a fire or a chip on your
shoulder to say
what's wrong is wrong i want to be able
to go expose it today are you kind of
over it i'm moving on
this is my country and i'm not giving it
away to
thugs period define thugs what i saw at
the fbi
[Music]
my guest today is someone that if you
google his name
you're gonna find articles you're not
gonna find a lot of stuff on him
let's just say he's not the most liked
guy for some of the stuff that he did
the right thing but he's not the most
like guy for some of the stuff he did
but let me kind of share with you his
resume
phd from duke university with post doc
from texas a
m three-tour veteran of vietnam war
youngest recipient of the navy medal of
heroism and it doesn't stop there
america's first
successful fbi whistleblower
and he changed the u.s criminal justice
system
forever my guest it is frederick
whitehurst
fred how are you i'm here
it's it's nobody shot me yet how are you
hiding like how
you know you're ready you go through the
story some of the stuff you've done is
which we'll get into here in a minute
but but is it intentional that you don't
want to have a lot of limelight and you
don't want people to see your story is
that a kind of a
intentional thing on your end patrick
the issue is not me
you know i i have asked not to be
um i'm not the highlight you know and i
shouldn't be
the issue is human rights violations the
issue is civil rights violations the
issue is truth
in our justice system the issue is the
strength of this nation
um i'm just a brick in a wall and i
choose to be
a brick and a wall the those folks who
want to be the wall
um they make things unsafe for
for all of us because when they fall the
whole wall falls
do you understand the analogy no
question about it sure
no question have you always had this
because you have this you have this aura
about yourself
where there are certain values and
principles
no one can uh uh break you up meaning
you're not gonna be
breaking a certain set of values and
principles that you live by
have you always been this kind of a true
believer or did some event take place in
your life
where you became a true believer no i
think um
i was raised by two very strong parents
a father who was a naval officer a
mother who was a very
outspoken social activist um
and they instilled in me my father
instilled in me you call a spade a spade
my mother instilled in me the the
concern for civil rights for truth
that that sort of thing um but i
gradually
uh if you will harden the medal in
combat in vietnam
i saw a lot of things in vietnam that
were wrong and then
you know of course in the fbi that story
is
you know you can look it up um i saw
things that were wrong i tried to
understand them
uh it didn't um it i never could
you know i did a lot of things to
understand
what am i seeing what am i what am i
saying wrong how am i how am i wrong but
you say have i always been that way
[Music]
i don't i don't know how to put that um
i've been me and i've i've matured in
in um into hardened steel if you will
uh hey it's it's wrong
tell me why i'm wrong because i think
it's wrong yeah
so yeah very obvious to feel that energy
from you but by the way
politically were your mom and dad both
on the same side politically
you know i don't know that politics was
um was not
an issue not a thing that in my family
i have three brothers and we're divided
um
[Music]
right down the center you know some of
us like me
are conservative uh republicans and some
of them like
a couple of my brothers are are very
liberal
um uh democrats if you will
so your parents kind of empowered you to
to be free thinkers and think for
yourself they never
imposed their political beliefs onto you
guys but they did
impose their values and principles onto
you yes that's correct
okay okay so so right after school
by the way if i'm in high school with
you who was fred in high school i'm
curious
fred was the kid that worked in the
lunchroom you know
um i got there at 5 30 in the morning
i went to work i wasn't uh i wasn't one
of the popular kids
um i didn't go to dances i didn't really
go to football games
there were things that interested me
that those things would get in the way
of
such as i i wanted to sail on boats i
wanted to
build rebuild machines i wanted to
landscape i wanted to work
my the work ethic in my family was
something that left us
work is finer than than fine spaghetti
if you will
i mean it's you know you wake up in the
morning and say what am i going to do
today and the last thing my wife and i
say at night is what did we accomplish
today
even though i'm 73 years old i've got to
do i got to accomplish something in my
day
you're 73 years old yes
good for you what kind of skin products
do you use i mean that's the first thing
my wife would ask you
like what are you are you like a estee
lauder or a mac guy because you use some
kind of skin product
you you got the right side i mean if you
look at the back side the hair is
falling out i've turned gray in the last
five years so
no skin products yeah listen you you you
look like uh tom select's
uh brother i mean we talked about it
earlier you got the voice you got the
mustache you got to look you
you look like you were one decision away
from being in hollywood if you wanted to
go that direction
well tom wants to be like me but he
can't quite get there
[Laughter]
so so let's go back so you're 18 you
like sailing you like building machines
that's what you're doing
did you go in the military simply
because pops was
a navy seal navy officer i think you
said he was a navy officer did you go in
because you just wanted to serve your
country
you know i went into the u.s army on a
whim
um i know people that went into the
people's liberation army in vietnam
the good friends that belonged to the
people liberation army that means the
army of north vietnam at the time
they went as a result of patriotism me
i woke up one morning i was trying to
accomplish a major in math chemistry and
physics in college i burned out i said
i'm leaving
i left i went to new york city the next
morning i woke up i joined the u.s army
when they asked me what do you want to
do i said i want to go to vietnam and
kill communists and that's what i told
them
every time you know i'm 73 i grew up in
the mccarthy age
you know and um at the time i believed
what
uh mad men told me i believed in the
domino theory and i believe that
you know i needed to protect my nation
from whatever that meant
um so when you say a matter of
patriotism
um for me i wish i were that kind of a
patriot
i i went um one morning i was a student
of science and math the next morning i
was a united states army recruit
and and how old were you when you got
your navy medal of heroism
oh well i was at the time the youngest
man in naval history who received the
navy marine corps medal i was 17.
my first day in the united states naval
reserve i jumped in a lake and saved one
guy from drowning and tried to save
another and lost him
and broke through ice to get into where
the car
had gone over this ledge and sunk in the
water but uh
yeah it was um it was a bad day it was
the 15th of january 1965.
so i was in the naval reserve um
and i stayed in the naval reserve for
about 18 months but i had a tendency
back then to walk in my sleep and you
can't walk in your sleep and being on a
united states navy
you walk overboard they don't know
you're overboard until you're close
so they gave me an honorable discharge
and
um oh three years later i went to new
york city to join the
the us army and they said have you been
in the military before and i said nope
haven't been in the military before i
was 20 at that time
they didn't find out i'd been in the
military until i was in vietnam for six
months and um
and went out of the infantry into
military intelligence
you're kidding me so so let me so you
get your honorable discharge after
getting your
medal of uh uh navy medal of heroes i'm
at 17 for jumping out of a
a helicopter to go save somebody and
then i didn't jump out of a helicopter i
swam off a shore
you swam off a shore and you saved one
and you lost one
yes and and and you said january 15
is uh i think it's a january 15 19 15
1965 yes 1965 and then you go to the
army
you go from infantry to military
intelligence
how did that happen to go from infantry
to mi
i saw things happening in the field that
i disagreed with
such as such as war crimes
you know people being harmed that
shouldn't and
i i found myself in an incident after
about six months where a
a young boy was being um brutally
just brutalized by some sick soldiers
and i just said you know i quit i don't
belong to this military i'm not going to
be part of this and the helicopter came
in and i got on it i went to the rear
and
and a couple of mps met me and put
handcuffs on me and
carried me over to the major who tried
to talk me out of reporting
the uh the issues and then they took me
to the colonel who
he tried to talk me out of it and um
i wasn't going to be talked out of it
you're not going to do that we're you
know we're the united states army
we're not bashing bazook of the ottoman
empire
where the united states army well he
said these things happen and
by the way you can't go back to the
field in my battalion because you're
going to get shot in the back of the
head by your own troops
what do you want to do so he offered me
a couple of alternatives and
and um the uh military intelligence
detachment down at
dukfo in quang night province um
needed me down there so i went down not
speaking vietnamese
i learned a little vietnamese when i was
in the field but um
but uh went down there and and stayed
with them for two and a half years
so you never ended up reporting it or he
the the soldier oh no i reported it
what happened to the soldiers that uh
you reported um what i
understand was there were six marines
and they were
um they got what's called an article 15.
that's um a slap on the hand yep it's
nothing um
you know they permanently destroyed that
14 13 year old kid
but um you know
it's not an excuse that it was wartime
when that visually stayed with you for
the rest of your life or no
the what is that visual of what they did
to that direction
i have a i have a horrible trait of
remembering things
vividly and um you know i mean
from from all of my life and yes i i
know what they did to that kid and i
remember getting on the helicopter i
remember the war officer telling me to
get
off of his helicopter with um words we
won't speak on this interview
and me just saying nope and reaching for
my 45 and
okay okay you settle down we'll take you
to the rear time i got off the
helicopter i
put my 45 on the ground and um
and a couple of mps came over and um and
they put handcuffs on me took me to
majors office well office tent whatever
but um what was happening was wrong
and i don't know patrick i don't know
how not to do something
you know i'm i'm it's going on
you it can't go on i'm going to try and
figure out why i'm wrong
i'm not going to denigrate people or or
look down on them but what you're doing
is wrong
in the united states military in the
americal division in vietnam
you know the me lie massacre well i got
there a year after the meal massacre in
the same unit in the same area
and i saw a lot of things that were
happening
that were bad they were they were
illegal or they were just bad
and so my concept of becoming an
interrogator prisoners of war was
okay somebody's going to come in and
they're going to tell me about this
stuff and i'm going to raise kane i'm
not going to tell the u.s media about it
but i'm going to raise cane so that
people will say okay
don't don't send it back there we got a
problem back there
and um so would you interrogating people
at the time
was that part of you were interrogator
and what was it what was your approach
because back then there was not a lot of
regulation you know it was a different
time than it is today what was your
approach to interrogating
well what you had was starving soldiers
brought down from the north who didn't
want to be there they had no idea they
didn't speak the language that we spoke
they were terrified
you could feed them you could clap them
on the shoulder you could treat them
nicely
they weren't being treated nicely by
their own political officers
they were they were starving to death
they were up in the
in the hills we cut off the rice lines
we put napalm all over the mountains to
get rid of the foliage
um they were they were very easily
convinced to
say there were some hardcore soldiers
that were never gonna talk but
you know in two and a half years i think
uh
i probably saw two or three of those
what was the difference between your
first tour your second tour and your
third tour
not a thing really a lot of thing um
i got there into the americal division
and march of
and left out of the americal division in
um
april of 1916 1872.
three years three years yes i went home
i went home every six months okay when
you extended
time in in country they give you a one
month leave to think it over
and i'd come back from the one month
leave and i'd go right into the
headquarters and i say okay i want
another six months which would give me
another full year
and they knew when i got off the plane i
was going to come up and sign up for
another six months so i had another full
year
got it i i saw i wasn't an officer i was
an enlisted man
i was a specialist five and i saw
i'm gonna go home and pick up cigarette
butts for some young
rotc you know officer who's gonna harass
me and
whatever i need to be if i'm a combat
soldier i need to be in combat
and i need to be with combat units and
so i just stayed
out there for three years
and what kind of reputation did you end
up building after what she did when you
reported those guys those marines the
six marines what reputation did you have
during those three years
you know there was a guy
that came one time and i picked him up
off the helicopter pad and they brought
him to the unit
and i helped him with his baggage and
um we got to his his tent you know
he did a whatever bag and i carried it
and we
about to go in the tent he said well
you're a nice guy they told me back at
headquarters you're a real son of a
[ __ ]
that's your reputation you had well
i'm a nice guy i'm a nice guy but
don't don't pull that stuff don't you
know this is the united states army
and and that's real that's not a concept
that's not
a idealistic thing this is the united
states
army and we're going to act like the
united states army and
you know that sounds maybe unrealistic
of me
i think armies win when they fight
ethically but
you know war messes people up
because you have to establish too often
your own morality
you have to decide them or them and it's
pretty much an everyday thing uh fred
you you get out of the army
you said you do three years there do you
fully get out or do you still stay in
the military afterwards
no i got out you're out okay so when you
got out so your opinion
of vietnam war when you first went in
when you first got out
and now in 2020
when i went in i went to vietnam to kill
communist when i got there i found poor
peasants
i found as a prisoner warren cater being
interrogated the people i was
interviewing were just people just like
me
they had been conscripted brought down
south
they they had a reason for fighting most
american soldiers didn't want to be
there
but i got to the point where i was in
vietnam of saying
i need to do this fight it was a foolish
concept but i need to fight this just as
hard as i can
i need to win this war so this will stop
of course you couldn't win the war the
united states would never have won
the vietnam war and
okay so when i came home
i ran away patrick and i hid i hid in
academia for 10 years
i finished my undergraduate degree in
chemistry
i went to duke i worked in a in an area
of chemistry called quantum chemistry
it's all theoretical mathematical um
sort of when you hear people talk about
quantum physics well okay quantum
chemistry
and then um uh i came out of that and i
came out of a postdoctoral fellowship
realizing that i
could not be an academician
i had to go back to war it's almost like
being an addict i have to do something
that means something every day rather
than
a long term i'm a simple man i want to
see results
every day i want to i want to make a
difference every day and so
i joined the fbi it took me 18 months to
get in but i joined the fbi
you know there's something very
inspirational about your mindset i got
to tell you there's something very
very inspirational about your mindset
and you're not trying to be motivational
you're just
explaining who you are you know for you
to say i want to be able to get results
on a daily basis i had to go back out to
be
i'm a simple man i have to figure out a
way to get results that's a
that's a very you know uh
common sense way of explaining how you
want to bring value to a nation where
you want to be
someone that's given back it's uh it's
it's it may be simple but this is coming
from a quantum chemist
so it's not like you're you gotta you
don't have a simple brain you don't have
a simple mind you don't have a simple
way of processing things
but your expectation is pretty simple so
you go into the fbi
when you go into the fbi 18 months later
what
what's now your goal the first one was i
want to kill commies
what do you want to do now oh well
darn i applied to work for the cia
before i applied work for the fbi
and and i love those guys they try to
find out if i was
if i still had a chip on my shoulder
from vietnam and i got an
interview with a guy hooked up to a
polygraph and he started insulting my
vietnam
service and so i reached across the desk
at him
that was the fourth interview
they thanked me for the interview and i
got back down to texas and i never heard
from them again
but during the interview process um i
don't worry i didn't assault the guy at
langley okay but um during the interview
process a friend of mine who worked on
his doctorate at duke um
was working for the fbi crime lab and he
said you ought to come over here you
have all the toys you want
and you can do good things with all the
toys you want so i went over and i went
through the lab
and oh my gosh and and dennis told me he
said
you can take on the the
biggest most expensive problems that's
that satisfy the objectives of this
organization
and have unlimited funding and unlimited
um whatever i mean it's at the peak of
the pyramid of the tax
structure of this country and that was
beautiful
and so i went back down to texas and i
applied to the fbi
and i just wanted to be a scientist i
wasn't have to be interested in being an
fbi agent i want to be a scientist but a
guy
came out of uh the houston office and he
came over and
to recruit me and he explained to me
that at that time is the way it was if
you weren't a scientist at the fbi
you're a second class citizen
you could move forward up the ladder
better if you were you know and get
things done
if you were a uh if you were a badged
agent so shucks i didn't want to carry a
gun again
you know i carried a gun i took lives
with guns i'm not a gun
person but i um
i applied to go to the academy
and um it took 18 months to
to get into my class 1982 classroom
class excuse me 3823 was my class at the
academy
and boy i i walked in there and
i was on cloud nine you know when
when you're when you're in that
environment you get full of hot air
you are someone you ain't nobody
you know you're just another joke on the
road with a doggone gun on your hip and
a piece of
of gold-plated metal in your pocket but
you are
someone do you know and
i spent the time at the academy very
much
dedicated to the academy and
then they sent me down to the houston
field office as a
new agent and well is that 86
no that's 1982. that's 1982.
came in to go into the academy on the
22nd of february i got out of the
academy on the 6th of june
um and
i got out of the field the 6th of june
of 82. i got out of the field i went to
the
sacramento field i mean the houston
field office the sacramento field office
has been the los angeles field office in
four years
and then i transferred to the where they
transferred me
to the lab on the 6th of june 86. is
that when you became the supervisory
special
agent uh from 86 to 98
at the lab well actually what i was
doing there
i spent the first year in training
and um after the first after 13 months
then i
uh i
i spent i think about a year before i
was a supervisory special agent
at the lab what what are some of the
assignments you had at that time that we
would know about or there were some big
assignments you worked on because
if i'm looking at that time 82 you're
you're reagan uh senior
and you got a little bit of clinton
that's when you were in i got a lot of
clinton i sued him in one
you sue clinton and one for like one and
a half million or some number like that
well i didn't sue him for the money i
sued him because
i wanted to implement the whistleblower
protection act
which was which was federal law
i wanted to implement it into the
department of justice and force him
we wanted to force him with a rid of
mandamus to to say
department of justice you got to obey
federal law which is bizarre but that's
where we were but
um the kinds of cases i worked on
initially were
it's low-level fugitive cases extortion
cases um bank robberies that kind of
thing
that was in the field i was in the field
in houston for six months went to
the chico california where i did
mostly narcotics investigations but
also bank robberies and fugitives then i
went down to los angeles for two years i
did
oh in 84 i got there and for two years i
narcotics investigations and then i went
to the lab and in the lab
oh i mean the cases you would have heard
about
were the first world trade center
bombing case
the pan am 103 case
oh let me see they're just a bunch of i
was in the o.j
simpson trial but i i was there
kicking and screaming i didn't work the
case but i reported issues in the case
and the defense picked up on
goodness what what happened with the
world trend what what what involvement
did you have in the world trade center
bombing case
that was the 93 bombing what happened
was
um i went to new york city
and set up an explosive residue analysis
testing laboratory in the nypd new york
police department
academy and we were having to look
through
40 000 tons of rubble that was a big
bomb
40 000 tons of rubble try to figure out
what kind of the explosive it was
and that went on for 12 days
and we were sleeping two hours a night
for 12 days and you can't do that
and continue to function and
then the lab became contaminated and so
we had to move evidence down to
fbi headquarters and so i i worked on
that i worked on the
the avianca 203 bombing case where
the fella named dandani munoz mosquiero
was accused of
blowing up avianca 203 and
i worked on the residue from that case
and i'm still working on that case
um let me see
the pan m103 i was over in
in england on that did some of that work
the 1993 case is that the one where you
were uh
you were responsible for securing a
crime scene and then which led to
uh later on uh you saw the forensic
misconduct which
later on you ended up exposing is that
kind of how the whole thing got started
no um
my training agent at the laboratory
um was i was there 90 days when he was
telling me how to commit perjury in
court
and i was very upset with that and his
work product was sloppy and i was very
upset with that
and so i started going through my chain
of command
the guys around me said they'd try to do
something about it for years and
the command didn't do anything about it
because he'd become a big liability for
the lab
and um i i
i didn't go outside initially
i was upset that you know
if you've done it there maybe if you've
committed perjury in one case maybe
you've done it in another and by the way
he never did commit the perjury he just
that was part of his training
you know that was part of what he told
me and we were required to report any
any indication of misconduct by fba
management fbi management
but they didn't want it reported they
just wanted to say
you need to report it and executive
order required to report
fraud waste abuse and corruption to the
appropriate authority
and so i i said okay well
here it is and the appropriate authority
initially
was a unit chief then it was an
assistant section chief then it was a
section chief then it was a deputy
director of the lab then it was the lab
director
then it was um
let me see who was it then um oh yes
i after i got it nobody doing anything
then then i wrote a letter to joe biden
okay when he was he was the
head of the senate judiciary committee
and and patrick this is a neat
a neat kind of a anecdote story
i get a letter back i wrote it clearly
as an fbi agent
i got a letter back and i'm sure it was
a staffer he didn't come from biden he
wouldn't
you know he didn't have time for that
but i got a letter back that said as a
as a federal prisoner i should refer
such issues to my prison legal uh
council you know
what that said to me very clearly was
joe biden did not want to get mixed up
with with um upsetting the fbi
he just he just wasn't why do you think
that is why do you think that is
the fbi is insidiously powerful
it's insidiously dangerous louis free
the director of the fbi actually said it
could be the most dangerous agency
in the united states until today
insidiously yes it could be
yes louis free was the director and he
made that comment publicly
he didn't say it was i'm saying
um we want to have a good guy
you know people want to look up to
something
and so they look up to the fbi is going
to save them
but the fbi is made of humans and
they're
in involved they're involved in a human
enterprise
and all human enterprises fail the
biggest failure the fbi's got
is it won't admit its failures it just
it won't so that we as a nation can can
help them fix them
but um when the fbi is doing background
investigations on
anybody that takes a seat up at the
at the hill well you know there's the
washington two step patrick
if you find out a staffer has been
involved in something he shouldn't have
maybe illegal you can do one of two
things you can either
report that or else you can put it in
your pocket and when you want access
you can then say to the staffer you know
you know you know you don't even have to
you know just you know um we like some
assistance
and um you know you remember back there
in
in podunk uh you know kentucky or what
you know boom um j edgar hoover was a
very powerful man
and his legacy is one of blackmail his
legacy is one of
well you know like people are talking
about mr epstein now
it was controlled by information
and until until
literally that's what my case involves
and i didn't even know it
i went into a lawyer's office and
they're the finest
whistleblower attorneys in the world but
i didn't know it at the time i just by
happenstance ended up there and i said i
don't care
if it means i die what's going on in the
fbi lab has got to be
stopped and my wife and i've decided we
will put our lives on the line
if necessary but these are human rights
violations
well that gave somebody um
somebody's the kind of go ahead this guy
doesn't care if they shoot him
well he cared but you know he's going to
go
where where he thinks this ought to go
so i'm sitting around
talking about mass spectrometers might
not work and protocols are not valid and
things like that
and other people are talking about let's
get oversight
let's get oversight of the fbi here and
so
years later um
as we're sitting around talking about
the old days somebody says what that
really was about
is getting oversight of the fbi
there needs to be oversight it says
guys in the bureau used to say don't
worry about it we're the investigators
and nobody investigates the
investigators
somebody needs to investigate the
who would that be though us
who's us the people you and me
and all of us yes has more power we the
people the fbi
or the government when i say government
i'm talking about
you know exact you know executive level
highest level
i think when you get to washington dc
the the fbi
trumps everybody they trump the
department of justice
they trump the white house they just
trump them okay that's too bad
but they trump and i think that's the
way it operates as a system
but the fbi i've been in there they are
absolutely terrified of the boogeyman
and the boogeyman is you
did you tell me more is you
it's the media it's the media they're
terrified
of public exposure they are absolutely
patrick terrified of public
exposure nobody wants you pointing their
camera or your camera
at the fbi agent will walk away from it
fbi managers oh my gosh they're
terrified
and it's a it's a culture of
we gotta hide we gotta hide we gotta
hide we have to hide
everything if that's the case why is
why does comey love the camera so much
you know he's using the camera he's
using it
what do you mean sure um
there are let's say
there's chicken eaters and there's egg
eaters boy does that sound strange
doesn't it
there's guys who are journalists who
will feed you up as their source
they've eaten the chicken they're not
going to get any more information then
there's egg eaters there's guys in the
media
who will continue to work with you work
with you
protect you as a source okay and they
get
a long stream of information till the
phone taps and everything catch up
hundreds of people in the fbi wanted to
come forward after i came forward
they said well the settlement the fbi
made with me became known as the wifers
deal
okay you're gonna pay me my paycheck
until i would normally retire because
you owe me that i
uphold my side of the contract but you
didn't then you're going to pay me my
retirement
and that wasn't a payoff to quiet me
down or i wouldn't be talking to you
right now
but i think when you go to dc
um when you go to the media right now
media is afraid a number of us
in the fbi who blew the whistle have put
together a book called
our fbi louis free put together a book
called
my fbi our fbi was written
by former agent rosemary du and she's a
very good author
and there's 15 or 16 folks that stories
were told and it's our fbi
uh something the effect of the way the
fbi
um suppresses whistleblowers or
retaliates against whistleblowers
whatever we cannot get
a publisher to publish it we cannot not
get
there nobody wants to touch it in fact
one of them actually said i don't want
to go
to war with the fbi again we can't get
anybody to put it out
and it's a textbook of
this is what will happen to you and
wait wait wait so so let me get this
straight so there is a book called
my fbi okay i just looked it up right
now
by louis fred right director of fbi
louis
director of fbi and this book was
written this is not a
newer book right by uh this was a book
written
and to give the exact time
uh it's not like the last couple years
this came out
2006 okay first edition oh six so we're
talking 14 years ago
when you guys wrote our fbi when did you
guys write that book
or when did she write the book about the
last we've been working on for about the
last three years
no one wants to publish the book nobody
wants to publish the book
she's about to self-publish it and
that's and that's craziness
that's craziness it's not about politics
patrick
it's not about politics you know people
every time an fbi
blok person blows the whistle they say
are you a democrat or a republican or a
liberal or
whatever that's not what it's about it's
about
this is what we said happened it's clear
that this has happened
and
we're not here to get paid off
we're not here to help somebody overcome
trump or overcome
hillary over whatever we're just saying
this is the way the fbi
um stops whistleblowers imagine this
federal law federal law the
whistleblower protection act was passed
in 1989.
the fbi refused to implement it
until 1996 1997
they refused to implement federal law at
the fbi
and they got away with it and
why we sued william clinton was
to get her rid of mandamus that means
get a court to order him
to implement federal law you know how
bizarre that is that's just bizarre
patrick
the senior law enforcement agency and
they want to declare the
the world but you know in the u.s will
not obey
the law it will not obey them let me
read what happened so maybe you can
unpack a little bit what happened in
1998 the fbi and the doj
agreed to settle with dr whitehurst
yourself
dr whitehurst's whistleblower
retaliation claims cleared his record
restored all of his rights
and paid him a record-breaking
settlement of 1.42 million dollars an
amount
unheard of for any federal employee
least of all an fbi agent what happened
there for them to pay the 1.42 million
the media
the congress um
i think the man that is the strongest
whistleblower advocate
in the united states in our
senate is charles grassley
you cannot bend that man you cannot
break that man
he is exactly what you want to know
a u.s senator should be
and he never quit he never quit
he has never quit just saying
you're going to adhere to the law and by
the way i want to know this information
and we
we we give you the money to enforce the
law now we want to know what you're
using it for
so he he there's no way to break
charles grassley he's a remarkable
person
um but the fbi was facing that
they were facing the media you know when
the o.j simpson trial came along i got
dragged in as the mystery witness
that all of a sudden put it on the uh oh
there's this fbi agent on the on the
national news
patrick i live in a town of 1600 people
my 1997 pickup truck has crank up
windows in it and that's who i am
i eat food out of the garden okay i had
to ask sam today the fellow that set
this up with us should i wear
my suspenders and my my um
what do you see all the lumberjack shirt
or should i put a suit on he told me
well it's up to you patrick doesn't care
okay
so you see a suit but we needed
i needed to stop what was happening
there
in the lab slanting rewriting reports
altering evidence people testifying
about things they had no idea about
but washington dc needed
to get a handle on the fbi which is out
of control
was out of control and
that that's what they told me that my
case really was about
um i'm just a quantum chemist who wants
to run a mass spectrometer the right way
yeah but why they pay to 1.42 million
when you're saying the media so
you're saying they wanted they wanted to
slant a story or they wanted to
write a report so are you saying that
they didn't want to tell the real truth
of what happened and you did and
were they trying to kind of undermine
your reputation no
i don't care about that what they did i
don't have a reputation anyhow
okay what they did patrick was to
um we
put forward to them this is the
settlement okay
um they had me under criminal
investigation they thought i had talked
to the media
okay but this is what this is what
needs to happen they agreed to admit to
cents 40 things that they'd done wrong
okay and they did
and the
president clinton agreed to
order the fbi and the u.s department of
justice to implement the whistleblower
protection act
he agreed to that and the us department
of justice
agreed finally they were the holdouts to
i wanted the contents of every file that
the 11 guys that i reported misconduct
their misconduct or malfeasance or
misfeasance i i wanted
the contents of every file they'd ever
worked on
and that was the largest freedom of
information act request of its kind in
the fbi's history
and i spent years acquiring it
and then documenting it and cataloging
it
and um i've got it all it's all
digitized
anybody that wants that information i
give it to them
there was a fellow in the hairs and
fibers unit who
was found to have lied in the hearing
involving a federal judge
and i thought if he lied in that hearing
and i didn't find it out another agent
sent a memo forward that said this guy
had given false and misleading testimony
27 times in a hearing involving a
federal judge i mean a federal judge was
being
was being investigated for crime okay
i figured if that guy did it with a
federal judge
who else could he have harmed so so far
i've collected the contents of about
cases that he worked on and men have
gone
free who have been in prison 20
30 and 40 years because of that man's
malfeasance
have gone free you can find their names
one of them is donald eugene gates
another one is sante tribble and sante
died recently
because of what happened to him in
prison in the horrible conditions he
suffered on her in other words kirk odom
and there's john huffington and the in
the names keep coming out they're like
ghosts coming out of a fog
because of one man one man and
then it turned out that his colleagues
had also been doing the same thing so in
2015 the fbi
admitted that 26 of 28
fbi hair examiners had given false and
misleading testimony
in their reports and or trial
90 percent of the time over a 30-year
period of time
and that's fbi admission patrick and i
can give you that
and that's horrible that that brings
tears to your eyes it's so horrible
because we need if i'm getting a little
too loud let me know patrick but lean
to depend on somebody we need to know
that our taxpayers dollars are going
into protecting us into
you real national security not a bunch
of people
trying to make a career of their careers
instead of
do their jobs you know it's amazing i
watch
now black lives matter and i'm cheering
them i'm a conservative old white
republican and i'm curing them
because they've had enough if you look
at the record of the people harmed
by those hairs and fibers analyses
you'll find most of them are people of
color
most of them are african-american and
nobody seems to pick up on that
on that that well he must be guilty
therefore the evidence is this is what
it means
that's wrong i you know i went to law
school i don't know if you noted that
but i went to georgetown
hi joe i went to georgetown and i got my
jd i went
because the deputy general counsel at
the fbi told me
when i went to her with these issues if
you just knew the law fred you'd
understand why these are not really
such big issues so i replied
to law school and georgetown accepted me
nobody else would
but georgetown accepted me i went to law
school
for four years at night while i was
suing the fbi and the u.s department of
justice and the president of the united
states and
all those people and um and things
and i got out of law school and the
the deputy general counsel is still
there and she said to me
fred that's just theory you need to
practice law
so i've practiced law for 16 years i've
been a criminal defense attorney for 16
years i got to tell you patrick
i've hated every microsecond of it i
hate the courtroom it's a place of
misery
it's a place of crime it's a place of
injustice
but at the end of it
i still think it's wrong for us to lie
in court
to present half a truth and by the way
the fbi lab is doing it
still doing it they moved and they
they recovered from that but now they've
moved back into it
i i watch fbi cases today and i look at
you know i'm i'm hired as a forensic
consultant
and i i see oh my goodness they're
rewriting reports and oh my goodness
they're talking about
stuff they don't know anything about and
they're mis misinterpreting data
you know i asked you a question i said
who's going to hold them accountable
so you said you who's me media okay
is me media or is me we the people which
one is you
you know what we the people read what
you the media published
okay media media has lost some of its
credibility too you know we've seen
we've seen that it's been politicized
but
one thing that's encouraging to me
literally and i've said it already
about black lives matter is that they've
had enough
those folks well right or wrong they
have had enough
and they've had enough and it's not
gonna
it's not gonna stop i pray it's not
gonna stop just because it got cold
you know it's not gonna stop because we
had our celebration this summer
and now we're going to go home and
things are going to be right
i think it's going to carry forward and
i think that demonstrates to this nation
we have had enough
this this thing that you represent
is supposed to be our thing and you've
made it into your thing
fred question at the time when you were
coming up so
one case john f kennedy so at that time
you said hoover earlier
who was more powerful at that time the
mob hoover or
jfk jfk jfk was more powerful at that
time yes that's right
then it's hoover dennis the mob did i
think
you said jfk at the top i'm very sorry
no
i i'm i'm sorry i misspoke no the fbi uh
so hoover was the most powerful in
america yes
who was after him
i don't know that he i don't know that
wait let me let me get this straight so
you're saying from
that time till today the fbi has it
always been where fbi has been more
powerful than the president
yes and i would say it this way i would
say it this way
until they met mr trump okay then they
met themselves
you know that's my opinion he's one can
be bullied around by that stuff
and you know i was laughing about it i
wasn't in love with mr trump but i was
laughing about
the fact that he he just wait you're not
doing that you're not coming over here
and doing that to me
i'm your boss you know and that famous
saying of his you're fired okay
but we had an fbi director the only fbi
director
in the fbi's history william sessions
who was a true
good american fbi agent a true good man
an ethical
good man that the fbi upper management
conspired against and got fired
william sessions was a i'll tell you
he sent a memo out to all personnel at
one time he said if you have an issue
that you
you have not do not feel it's been
addressed i want to know about it
come to my office when i got that memo i
picked the phone up immediately the memo
was in my hand
his secretary said come up right now
that doesn't happen at the fbi a
mid-level manager like me goes up to the
yes and he listened to me for 45 minutes
that was a national leader and then two
weeks later he brought me back with his
general counsel
and they talked to me for two hours get
out of here
yes and i was talking to him about the
problems in the lab
and this is the director of fbi at the
time this is correct
six years william sessions
yes and then shortly after that he got
fired
he got set up by his upper management
because he was bringing some sense of
of good to us
so let me ask you since since you've
been out since you've been out
okay so you you're done you know
you get your obviously lawsuit settled
1.42
1998 that's 22 years ago what have you
been doing the last 22 years
well um for five years after i got out i
was offering my services as a consultant
in forensic science i was going through
fbi documents and watching how they were
handling cases
and looking at what they were how they
were progressing and they progressed
patrick
they're light years from where they were
when i got out okay
but the rot is sneaking back in but
after five years i live in a small
county in the middle of nowhere in north
carolina okay
after five years i
said well i got a law degree and i don't
understand these guys around here i'm
offering my services free and nobody's
calling me
so i said well i need to go over to the
courthouse start practicing law and find
out
what's going on and so i went over
and by the way nobody would hire me
nobody wants to hire somebody that sued
the president
you know that's trouble around the
office i mean nobody anywhere would hire
me
but that was okay i needed to work for
myself and
i took the bar exam and failed it and
took the bar exam and failed it and then
i took the bar exam and passed it
then i went over to the courthouse and
for about 90 days i sat in the courtroom
trying to figure out what in the dickens
is going on
and then i went over the public
defender's office and
put my name on the indigent defense list
and started
uh going to court with folks and
i got to tell you what goes on in the
courtroom has nothing to do with what
goes on in
in law school it's like you know
if you don't go in as an apprentice for
somebody you are lost
so i started defending folks
to understand why court
the courtrooms allow garbage in the name
of science
name science it's garbage to be entered
as evidence
and then i started consulting heavily
and it was a point which had about 250
cases i was representing
which is crazy impossible
and i learned the culture of the
courtroom
is a big reason why the forensic science
gets away with what it gets away with
when you go into a courtroom and there's
12 to 2500 people coming through that
courtroom in one day
one day and they have 360 minutes to
parse
among all of them you can't say fourier
transform infrared spectrophotometry
you can't say gas chromatography mass
spectrometry you've got a line up behind
the rest of the attorneys waiting for
two or three prosecutors possibly only
one
hand them your your your bid for freedom
they give you back their bid you go to
your client you come back
you i mean it's going it's a it is a
production line
and concepts of validation of scientific
protocols
are way way outside
the sphere of people that practice law
every day
that literally go into court so so let
me ask you
did what you do the last 22 years
distract you from going back and holding
the
fbi accountable where you were kind of
like why i did my part i'm moving on to
becoming an attorney
or is there still the fire right now
where the last 22 years have taught you
on how to go out there and expose
more today meaning is there still a
inspiration is there still a fire or a
chip on your shoulder to say
what's wrong is wrong i want to be able
to go expose it today are you kind of
over it i'm moving on
i will die exposing
i will die raising questions i mean
i'm saying it's 73 i got until i'm blind
until i can't get out of bed until i
will do this till the day i die
this is my country and i'm not giving it
away to
thugs period define thugs
thugs what i saw at the fbi
altar of reports
alter evidence lie in court
uh intimidate people on the street
all of that you know i'm not giving it
up to them
i'm going to fight smart you know the
viet cong taught me fight to fight again
you know they didn't stand up and shoot
at you they they came out of a hole shot
at you and came back in the hole fight
to fight again
fight smart but i'm not giving my
country away
i'm not going to it's mine
and if everybody else wants to give it
away that's just fine
so i look at their protocols
i look at whether they validated things
or not i raise issues
validate means and i'll tell you the
folks who may hear this may not
understand what i'm saying
okay when i ask you a question you give
me an answer but did you give me the
right answer
you had a method which you used to give
me an answer
is it is it a method that gave the right
answer did
if you validated it forensic science
didn't even understand that
they didn't understand that until about
supreme court law dauber versus mayoral
pharmaceuticals came out and said
if you're going to come into a court of
law with evidence you've got to tell us
if you use the right process to get to
it
he's sort of if we hearken back to matt
versus ohio
it used to be that officers beat
confessions out of people
well then you get the suppression of
evidence
okay we're not going to accept that
evidence because it's more important
that we do this job right
well what happened was the the night
sticks just
traded for people in crime laboratories
you're either going to do it right and
give us the answer
and prove how you got that answer
or else you're not going to do it well
it's taken over 20 1993
what is that 20 years or whatever um
and courts are still not accepting that
you walk in with a badge and a gun and
you're an fbi agent and by
golly we better believe those boys in
blue
no there are boys in blue who cross the
blue line
you know that expression i didn't cross
the blue line they crossed
they go outside the
honorable profession of being law
enforcement officer
and we have a difficulty pointing our
fingers at them
because very often they are false heroes
so fred who fears them the most who
fears the fbi the most
i think the nation is afraid of the fbi
you think so you think the nation as
people is afraid of the fbi
i think so sir tell me tell me why you
think
the nation is afraid of the fbi
you know the fbi in many ways it
represents a national security threat
and nobody's doing anything about it
if i know what you're going to say i can
make you say anything i want you to
if i know that your primary purpose in
life is to become promoted
so that you're making more salary i can
get you
promoted if you say what i want you to
i can do that then when we have national
security threat
like let's say weapons of mass
destruction
i watched that silliness
and where was iraq you know
and i and i heard military officers say
to me we saw
from our satellites what was coming out
of those that's those
those tractor-trailer trucks
okay you can't see from 30 000
feet in the air much less 30 000 or
whatever you can't
it's not possible but you get people to
say it
and then what have we got we're we're
running off on boondoggles following
faults
the american people need to demand more
than that
and i think when the media says we won't
publish
our fbi
you know they don't feel solidly on
footing to put out information that's
valid information
that can be tested and checked and
documented they they're okay
they're not sure that the people will
back them
and the people people are afraid of the
fbi
and that's too bad who dislikes you
who is afraid of you or people like you
i think the people that that dislike
people like me
are those that are guilty i think so
there are guys there you know i don't
know what you're going to do with this
footage but there are fbi agents
that will be infuriated by what i'm
saying
they will think that i cross the blue
line i have friends very good and close
friends who are still
well they're out of the fbi now but that
will tell me about conversations they go
into where people say
that guy's a nut he's a trader
okay well so i'm a nut
oh okay but i present to you
u.s government documentation to say
what i'm saying don't trust me
don't trust the fbi ask for the data
ask for the process and you know what
we're not going into court and
asking for i want your data and i want
your protocol
and i don't care if it's the data from
an investigation in the field
or if it's in the laboratory or what i
want to see it and we're not doing that
and i think we're we're not doing that
out of
of laziness i think we're not doing that
out of fear
out of fear what's going to happen is he
going to start looking at
my computer
searches or is he going to look at my
taxes or is he going to harass me
or is what is he going to show up at my
job and ask my boss if i'm there
knowing my boss is afraid of him so i'll
lose my all of that stuff
you need to get a handle on that patrick
so then that means the business model of
the
if because if you're saying that to me
first place i go to is the business
model of an fbi agent doesn't work
meaning
if i have to worry about kissing your
ass to get a promotion
that model doesn't work in the fbi if
that makes any sense i don't know if i'm
making any sense on what i'm saying
the business model has to be based on
markers i hit whether you like it or not
yes sir uh uh uh and how you do that i
don't know how you do that i'm not in
that world
uh uh i know every business has a
certain form of a compensation structure
on how they pay people
and sometimes a certain comp plan can
create bad habits so if you're saying i
need to kiss someone's ass to get a
promotion that is definitely not a good
comp structure set up for
fbi agents i wouldn't want that kind of
account for fbi agents
well you give the right answer to the
right guy
to the right question at the right time
to get the right job
and that's the model and that's the
model it's not effective i mean i i
just i think denny's and there's no
accountability yeah if you make a
mistake there's no account you know what
i don't know what business you're in
patrick but if you're selling a product
okay and you sell a product that doesn't
work
but you know what you got a business
there's no there's no accountability
there
so if you've got no accountability
you've got to have maximum oversight
every time you take a step you take a
step
someone has to look over your shoulder
as a public policy reason to have no
accountability for law enforcement
because
law enforcement be sued continually and
be put out of work
that's been carried too far and this
movement in this country right now
to start naming names and giving
citizens the right to sue law
enforcement officers who
you know pull this stuff of
um shooting folks in the back who are
running from them and things like that
the man
who put donald eugene gates in prison
for 28
years of his life
lives in a nice corner lot in a nice
suburb
making a bunch of money and for
three years after he got out of the
bureau there was the things i raised
about him then the fbi hired him again
as a contract employee
they let him go when i when
during a new revelations coming out i
called a newspaper a well-known
newspaper and i said would you ask the
question publicly why is he still
working for the fbi
when you know these things have happened
okay
and they did and the fbi let him go that
day
there is no accountability they should
go and seize his retirement check
seize his home sees all his property i
don't care where he goes
i'm sorry he can live an apartment
someplace if he can afford it
take it all away and use it to
try to make hole though you will never
make hole those people
that he put down for decades with false
and misleading testimony
and the government has admitted this man
did this
there's a case out there us versus derry
nelson
there he spent 33 years in prison
he got out about two years ago after we
fought for about four years
he got out now he's waiting to be tried
again for murder
and the government admits and the court
admits
that the evidence presented by that
particular fbi agent was lies
in fabrications and the court of appeals
says it was perjury
there's no accountability for that agent
he's beyond accountability
patrick you know
um if there is no accountability there
has to be
absolute total oversight every day
people are monitoring what's going their
cameras everything you do
everything you do there's a camera
pointed in
otherwise you don't fear anything
but you do want to get ahead and get to
be the section chief
or the deputy director or go to the rose
garden and have somebody put a medal on
you
you know yeah so yes
kissing ass doesn't give a good product
the promotion that way but
um it's the it's the format for the fbi
you know i'm looking at a number right
now from gallup say fbi
positive job rating steady among
americans this is from a year ago
may of 2019 it says
to give you this specific numbers 57
percent of americans say the fbi is
doing an
excellent or a good job okay
57 this is from gallup there's another
one that says 76 percent which is from
courthouse news
saying 76 percent of americans think
that
the fbi is doing a good job uh
do you think america looks at fbi in a
trusting way and they say
you know i don't know what fred is
talking about i just think he's a former
disgruntled fbi agent he just you know
somebody probably pissed him off and i
get it you know good for him you know
something probably happened
and more power to them you know but most
fbi agents are good guys and they're
doing the right things and i i don't
think they have the power it's like cops
you know one
one cop doesn't ruin all cops of course
there's bad cops but not all cops are
bad cops
you know i think it's just over
exaggerating what would you say to that
i would say first of all most fbi agents
are good folks
and i testified to that on the senate
you know
don't paint this with too narrow a brush
and don't paint it with too broad a
brush
most fbi employees are good people they
do have a
a moral dilemma they have to face um
do i hold my oath or do i keep my family
safe okay
but they're good people what happens is
the management of the fbi
is is phenomenally in my opinion corrupt
and i think when you go to the field and
you ask deal agents about what they
refer to as view humps
bu as in boy uniform
bravo uniform view humps nobody has a
good opinion of view homes they are
people
that gave the right answer the right guy
to get the right job the right time that
sort of thing
okay um i think that it's sort of like
what you said about most think is doing
a good job
there are people on the street that
think i'm a good attorney
how do they know whether i'm a good
attorney or not they're not attorneys
they can't judge me how did anybody know
that agent that put that put that man
in prison for 28 years based on false
and misleading testimony
how did anyone know that that agent was
not a good guy
when you looked at him he was an agent's
agent
he was a very handsome man he was tall
he was built he was you know he was
soft-spoken
and he was an out-and-out liar
he was a psychopath in my opinion okay
how would anybody know that he got three
attorneys generals awards
i mean the u united states department of
justice gave him three awards
and then one day i'm in this other
agent's office
and the agent pulls out a memo he wrote
on the third day of august 1989 and he
says
that psychopath gave false and
misleading testimony 27 times
in a hearing involving a federal judge
by the name of alcy hastings
who is now a senior u.s congressman
and he gave me that memo
and i copied that memo and the world
would have never seen that memo and that
memo was to that agent's boss
to telling this is going on
and we need to fix this or do something
about it or the fbi's reputation is
going to suffer okay
how would you how would the american
people know whether fbi agents are doing
the job right
by looking at the work product
of the office of congressional and
public affairs
they got more agents worried about the
media representation
and what the public perceives of them
than they do about some major crime
areas
there's a hundreds of people in the
office of congressional and public
affairs
okay and those guys are continually
feeding
misinformation and so you see today's
fbi
you see you know there's an fbi show on
right now where there's a woman agent
and a middle eastern guy who's an agent
and
you say boy and those of us that have
been in the fbi
there's a glass ceiling that's that's
silliness that's silliness
you know that's not what happens in the
fbi
the fbi is an old white man's
organization
and it stays that way by brute force
is it really yes if you call say
call on rosemary do or whatever you know
and look at
and look at some of the underlying a
friend of mine
a friend of mine just got out of prison
on the 18th of this month
he was an fbi agent he got four years he
can't talk about it
but um he got four years because
he did not want to go into
muslim communities of immigrants
and force people in the religious
community
to stitch on their people in the
community he want to do it
and he went about
revealing it in a way that the fbi was
able to get him convicted to four years
four years in second sentence he's just
got out after two
the american people do not know the
problems in the fbi
and they can't know the j edgar hoover
building is a
bunker and you're not allowed in
who's who's working hard right now to
expose them
and who do you think can be successful
at doing that is it even possible
senator charles grassley that's the one
you were talking about earlier
senator charles as an american hero
who's the biggest name that has his back
even bigger than him more powerful than
him
senator charles grassley is the
foundation
okay got it holding he is holding up the
building
what's what's supporting senator charles
grassley is the fact that he
he is above reproach
period oh what say that one more time
he's above reproach he's
above the fbi tricks completely above it
he is an american hero he is the
american hero
period he's 87 years old
yes
and i'm 73 patrick there's a big
difference between 87 and 73. that's
right
there's a big difference isn't it
amazing
well in today's times you know 73 we
have a 78 euro president-elect and a
74-year-old president today
yes so so today actually
that you that would be considered old
long time ago not today today it's we're
living a different time
um you know you were
you eventually joined the board of
directors at the national uh
whistleblower
center and you helped fight cases where
misconduct has been involved helping
innocent people get out of jail and
you've been doing that
you know several of the things you
worked on what do you think about what
talsie gabbard said recently
when she said she believes trump should
pardon
uh julian assange and edward snorton i
don't know if you caught that or not but
she just said that a few days ago
i have heard that
i met at odds with mr snowden
you know what mr snowden pointed out
was that there was not a place he could
go to
in our national security agencies that
was
would work that's what he pointed out
the secrets that he let go
um that i understand i don't have
firsthand knowledge that are damaging to
national security
makes me say
you know there's got to be another way
there's got to be another way nsa cia
intelligence community whatever there's
got to be
another way to do this
besides when whistleblowers are not
allowed to report internally
then they're like me they finally just
go out
and it creates a distrust
but management if snowden was a
righteous
he had righteous concerns so did my
friend that just got out of prison after
two four years since but two years in
okay
righteous concerns the bullies
in those organizations will not
seriously consider the concerns
and try to address them and
you know as a as a nation
we're concerned about that stuff should
they give him a pardon
i am personally afraid of anything that
donald trump does i'm a republican i'm
an old conservative white man republican
okay
but i am concerned about anything he
does he's
he frightens me in his amateur way of
going about what he's going about
can you unpack that you said he's going
through things in an
amateur way can you unpack it what do
you mean by that
he's an amateur he's not out of dc he
doesn't understand the nuances of what
he's doing
and he's some of the some of his ideas
are good ideas but um
to continually get caught in lies in
inappropriate activity and behavior
and you know misogynistic whatever and
all of that stuff to encourage white
supremacists or whatever
that's that's that's a that's an amateur
that's an amateur
leading this country takes a
professional
and
it's too bad because we need that
whatever it is that sort of i'm going to
stand in your face
but we also need some substance behind
it and i'm i'm afraid
donald doesn't have that substance
that's my personal opinion
no it's it's your perspective is is hurt
you know it's
who would you say was a good combination
of having a backbone and still
knowing how to play the political game
who was a good combination of both
well i'll i'll announce in your show i i
voted for kamala harris
you look for kamala harris i did i voted
for i voted for
joe biden because he's tagged along with
cameron
but she's been a public servant her
whole life
i want to see equality in this nation
i want to see someone who's an attorney
who's been in court
who understands our legal system i wanna
i
i've been up against her at at a
distance
in a court case i went through in san
francisco where she was
actually providing cover for somebody
that was providing bad information she
didn't know it
but um when i went down there
that's that's why that's my finger went
my pen went on that
um who who are your all-time favorite
presidents i'm curious like who else
have you voted for who do you look at as
a
president i love ronald reagan you know
uh i know ronald had his faults but i
love ronald reagan i'm just sorry that
he was a hollywood cowboy
you know um
and the first time the first time i
voted for
barack obama i was pleased that barack's
personal life
didn't get crowded into the media all
the time exposure i'm so tired of that
you know um but i didn't vote for
anybody the next time
i'm i was afraid that he went way too
far in the other direction
and and created donald trump as what i
think he did
did you vote for trump or no no
um i did not vote for trump
i couldn't vote for anybody in that
election
got it got it uh uh uh
interesting uh interesting perspective
for you to not
uh support a trump
pardoning assange and edward snort
snowden because they would be
whistleblowers
and why not pardon them so they can be
free
it's very interesting because you're
very uh
you're you're you're tough to put in a
place because you're all
you're you're in different places
politically
but who you vote for what you like what
you dislike you like
trump's personality to go up against the
fbi because you thought he was the right
guy that could go up against fbi but you
didn't vote for him you voted for kamala
hairs
because you like her approach works you
know you're very interesting where you
are and how you process
issues very very interesting i have to
say this to you um
you know i'd like to do a quick uh speed
round i'll give you a name
and tell me the first thing that comes
to mind i'll give you one name and tell
me the first thing that comes to mind
uh putin
a quick name would be trump okay
comey
i don't have a name for him unless you
want me to say something
oh it's not a name any word any word
that comes to mind you can tell
call comes to mind the word
problem so what would come to mind for
putin
putin trump okay got it how about trump
putin okay kamala harris
rosa parks carter jimmy carter
lincoln okay reagan
roy rogers roy rogers obama
clean clean clean
okay julian assange
dirty snowden
confused aoc
dangerous bill clinton
dangerous biden
politician hillary
very dangerous you are so interesting
william sessions
patriot
i got to tell you i've enjoyed this uh
uh conversation with you
very much so i've really enjoyed talking
to you you know your perspective is very
uh
um obviously
you know the one thing is very very
clear with you
you're uh unbreakable with your beliefs
your true believer
of where you're at you're not willing to
compromise that
you're calling out you know who
you consider being one of the most
powerful institutions that have not
are not held accountable by anybody um
and i'm really curious to know what
you're going to do at the young age of
73. like i'm really curious to know what
you're going to do next because
if you're talking about senator grassley
at 87
being the one that's going around you
know driving his initiative
and he's the leader to be able to hold
fbi accountable and you're 73
that means uh you you got some fresh you
know
legs to be able to make a run at some
things you can expose
and i'm very curious and looking forward
to seeing what you're going to be doing
well are you asking me a question or
telling me good night
[Laughter]
i'm going to leave it open-ended for you
to have closing thoughts you have the
final word
what do you want to say before we wrap
this up
what i'm going to do is keep watching
this is my country and i'm going to keep
watching the people that i
think are failing
and raising issues about those failures
i'm not going to move to washington dc
i'm not going to run for public office
i've learned what i need to learn in a
court of law and so i'm not going to
represent defendants in courts of law
but my my
strong point is science and
just saying you know this is the way i
see it i may be wrong
but this is the way i see it
and i i think finishing up i'm going to
continue to collect data
and it's you know it's us government
documents
or if it's data from crime laboratories
or if it's
testimonies from courts or whatever i'm
going to continue to collect data
and give it away to anybody that wants
it
well let us know if you got anything new
you want to share with us we're here
to uh if you got anything you want to
share with uh
the world because they're curious as
well they're curious as well
so thank you so much for being a guest
uh i know we're not gonna be
speaking probably in the month of
december if we don't happy holidays
merry christmas and happy new year to
you and to you too sir
thank you okay how can that story be so
secretive where not many people have
heard their stories isn't it interesting
if you go online right now you type in
his name you're not going to find out
you'll see wikipedia
but you're not going to find anything i
mean you're not going to find videos
interviews
nothing of him and to have that
fascinating of an interview to be that
stubbornly curious that you want to know
powerful story by the way
curious you know what you took away from
it and uh if you enjoyed this i mean he
still got me thinking i literally just
got out of the interview
if you enjoyed this interview you would
also enjoy an interview i do with
michael mcgowan former fbi agent who
went up against the sinaloa cartel
and la cosa nostra if you've never
watched us click over here to watch that
interview
similar story nobody knew him until we
did the interview and then he ended up
getting a million views
or so and he's also got a fascinating
interview and if you've not subscribed
to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye